.
Thank you.
so I'm still the same person who testified last week in front of this committee I'm representing Timothy Horrigan from Stratford County District 6 to towns of Durham and Madbury.
I'm here to introduce HB 60FN relative to school lunches and establishing the Meals for Students Fund.
Those of you who have been on the committee, we've had similar bills in the past.
Actually, it's something of a misnomer because it also deals with school breakfasts.
It makes basically two changes.
This is RSA 18911 11 a which deals with food and nutrition programs in public schools the first change in section one requires all schools provide both breakfast and lunch which I think many of them doing and that's I think that's been the subject of a think there's other bills I think there's at least one other bill bill which would make both breakfast like make breakfast universal, school breakfast universal in New Hampshire.
And that change would be permanent if you pass the bill as is.
And the second change is in sections 2 for 4.
It's actually going to apply only to July 1st 2025 it's a little over three years that's the date is the beginning of this state's fy 2026 fiscal year it's also and it's also about when the current stimulus and covid relief federal funds would run out i certainly i certainly would hope this committee and our finance committee would revisit this issue in 2024 and do a more permanent thing, but this is just for the next budget cycle, the remainder of this budget cycle and then the next one.
So it reduced families' co-pay, reduced price meal from zero from the current, what I have here is 30 cents per day for breakfast and 40 cents per day for lunch.
The fiscal note seems to have different information on it, but the fiscal note is probably right.
The existing distinction between free lunch and reduced price lunch families would stay in place along with all the procedures associated with that distinction.
The key difference if this bill becomes law would be that the approximately 9,000 students in the reduced price category would, going forward, get free lunches and breakfasts.
And Section 4 of the bill is identical to existing law.
It's a somewhat convoluted way of changing the law for three years and then changing back to the way it is right now.
And I certainly would be amenable to maybe not necessarily going back to the old law, but that's what this bill said.
That seemed like the safest thing.
The rationale for changing the law for just three years is basically, I may not know much about as many of the committee, but federal funding appears to be readily available through the Biden administration's economic stimulus and pandemic relief packages, and also the state budget is, rather ironically, after all the strange things that happened, the last two or three years actually is running a surplus at the moment.
So a rainy day fund, for example, is, I think, something like $275 million, but anyway.
And the federal funding, federal funding we go into a new meals for students fund this dedicated fund could actually receive money from any source not just from the federal government but also from the private sector or even from the state government itself and as I said if this no-cost school lunches and breakfast proves to be popular and feasible then the expansion you know could be this issue can be addressed during the uh 20 in 2025 during the 26-27 biennial budget process actually in theory we could probably even do it next year in 2023 we're doing the 2024-2025 budget so the fiscal note was accurate to me states this proposal would650,000 a year and directly benefit about 9,000 students, which, as I said, I'm confident that federal funding can be found.
And even the absence of federal funding, I think this is a good and relatively inexpensive program, which is, well, spending even our own money on, much as we don't like to do that here in New Hampshire.
But I think it's worth it.
And so other states have gone much farther than this.
California and Maine are putting in programs to give free breakfasts and free school meals to every student in the public schools and the other schools that participate in the school nutrition program, which that actually would be like relatively be, that actually would be like relatively, not relatively, that would actually be surprisingly inexpensive.
But that's not what this bill does.
We're just addressing this piece of it.
And also one more side benefit is schools are often having trouble getting parents to apply for the reduced price meals either because they, well, of course, many school districts, including the one in my community, have been doing free meals since the pandemic started just because for various reasons it's worth spending the money to give everyone a free meal whether they're like eligible for a subsidized meal or not.
But anyway, that's something that you probably want to look at in the future.
Maybe not this week.
So I think hopefully everyone will agree that if we can find the funding, the policy is a good one.
And so I hope you will find it out to pass.
So basically that's my testimony.
So thanks.
Thank you very much, Representative.
Are there any questions?
Yes, Representative Woodcock.
Thank you, Chairman.
Representative Holken, I just want to make clear I understand we've had a couple of bills very similar to this in this session.
I want to make sure I understand the difference between this and the other two.
Okay.
Your bill would take, if I understand you correctly, would take the folks or youngsters who are on free or reduced lunch, make them a free lunch, and include the lunch which we haven't previously done.
So you're expanding this so there is no cost.
If my youngster was on a reduced meal schedule, this would now be eliminated just via zero fee.
Yes.
I guess it would still be classified as reduced lunch just because of all the...
Right.
Okay.
I mean...
I just want to make sure I was very clear.
Thank you, Chairman.
Thank you.
Further questions?
Representative Hill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
And thank you for your welcome to the committee.
Appreciate your testimony, Representative.
I have a question about the last page of the fiscal fiscal note, and I'm wondering if you have a solution to the additional startup cost, labor cost, cost of meal pricing, projected participation, and actual participation for those 170 schools that they are concerned about.
I know the school district in my community has a real hard time with labor, and I'm wondering if that's something that you've thought of.
Well, I didn't write the fiscal note.
I mean, I did do my own back- the envelope calculations and it seemed to be correct insofar as, I mean, some of that's impossible to know with 100% certainty.
So that's, yeah, but there is a lot of labor involved with keeping the school cafeterias going regardless of whether or not we pass this bill.
I don't, so I think that's a problem they're faced with.
That's a problem they're faced with regardless of what we do with the bill and this bill would at least direct a few more dollars to the school.
So that's Thank you.
You can bring something in from LBA.
LBA might be telling you more like why they, and education might be more detailed why they brought those numbers.
Thank you very much.
Are there additional questions from the committee?
Not seeing any.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Are there any other folks in the group in front of us that would like to testify?
You came as a technical support.
Are there any questions from the department for technical support?
Not seeing any hands?
Yeah, could we just find out what the feasibility of implementation would be Sure.
McKenzie, could you come up please?
I know there's been some timing of questions before.
Mackenzie, could you come up, please?
I know there's been some timing.
You have a question from Representative Luno.
Thank you very much for joining us this morning and for taking the question.
I'm just interested in your thoughts regarding the effective date and implementation of this bill.
Thank you for the question.
So if the bill is only intended to ensure that we are fully reimbursing reduced lunch students, so making up that gap, that 40 cents gap, to make reduced lunch students free for those participating in an slp that is something that could be implemented on a quicker timeline if the bill intends to expand lunch and breakfast provision requirements to those schools not participating in an slp at all which include about 54 public schools and about 140 private schools, then that would require significant startup time per our testimony on similar bills.
And the startup cost as estimated independently has been around $23,000 per school not providing any sort of school nutrition program whether that be breakfast or lunch the other piece to note again is that of the 466 schools participating in an SLP 30 of those do not participate in breakfast so there would be a lag potentially in time required to be able to provide breakfast in addition to lunch for those NSLP participants currently doing so.
Thank you.
Representative Lycus, do you have a question for the department?
Yeah, it just occurred to me to wonder, and maybe either the sponsor or you could answer this, who is responsible then for all of the startup costs in starting those 30 schools doing lunch?
And I know we can't know what that is because it all depends upon the individual school, but who would be responsible for paying for that so that that's not addressed in the proposal at the legislative proposal as we understand it so that would fall to the school district the school and local expenditures likely and that's why those are indeterminable.
Right.
Thank you.
Are there further questions of the department?
Not seeing any.
Thank you very much.
With that, we're going to close this hearing.
We only had one pink card.
Did you have any people signing in on that, Representative Porter?
Okay, that's your job.
I had the impression that you didn't want me to do it.
Really?
Yes.
But I will continue if you would like.
Well, the only thing is the sign-up of positioning can go through the day.
So what we can put an indicator.
So with that, we're done this hearing.
And what we're going to do right now, we're going to break into caucuses.
At least the Republicans are going to caucus.
And from what I understand, Representative Luno had indicated he would like to do the same.
So what we're going to do is we're going to break for our caucus right now, and we will come back in how much time do you need, Dave?
What time would you like to start?
Well, this hearing was, you know, scheduled just to start.
Of course, that can stop any time because it's a hearing.
So I'd like to, you know, take it.
Thank you.
This hearing was, you know, scheduled just to start.
Of course, that can stop any time because it's a hearing.
So I'd like to, you know, take a quarter of ten or ten of ten, thereabouts.
Yes, okay.
Okay, good.
I don't know if there's other rooms available.
Maybe just right across the hallway if there's nothing going on.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
So with that, we're going to break into caucuses, and we'll come back at approximately 10 to 10.
Thank you.
Okay, we're going to go ahead here.
We've just done some huddling up here.
We're going to try and move this thing and get out of here by 1 o'clock.
So, folks, if you know how you're going to go and approach that, let's just get there without a lot of discussion and try to wrap this thing up.
I think we can do it.
Do you think we can do it, Representative Luno?
I think we can do it following our conversation.
Conversation, okay.
Okay, so with that, we're going to start right off with HB, and we're going to use the list that you have in front of you, Representative Luno, and I have in front of me.
HB 1574, I'm looking to Representative Moffittitt for a motion, please.
And we'll get to 1574 here.
Yeah, thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Yes, this is the measure on school tuition for art estate students.
Frankly, I move ITL.
That's correct.
We have a motion on the floor.
Brief discussion, please, from either the maker or the second, and then if there's on the other side.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Very briefly, I think this was, frankly, kind of a mischief bill that was submitted.
I think the intent of it was to shine a light on out-of-state students voting.
And I think it shined that light.
And I don't think it's a realistic, financially speaking, to OTP.
So I recommended ITL.
You're talking about that $130 million.
Okay, does the second have any discussion?
Nothing to add.
Thank you.
Is there any further discussion?
Representative Luno?
Thanks.
I think we're good with the motion being made.
Thank you.
Madam Clerk, and this is right on the top side where Melissa's had to do the clerking, so please bear with us.
So learning experience.
I thought we were moving this along.
All right.
Rep.
Bone.
Yes.
Melissa, Rep.
Litchfield, the clerk.
Excuse me.
Can we teach you a moment?
You've got to say the bill number and or i can do that too either one so um and the motion that's correct no no no so basically i'll help you right out.
It's 1574.
If I get to it here.
It's an act prohibiting the university system and community college systems of New Hampshire from charging out-of-state tuition to students voting in New Hampshire.
Okay, and this is HB 1574 with a motion of ITL.
Representative Boehm.
Yes.
Representative Litchfield.
Representative Lakers.
Yes.
Representative Moffat.
Representative Hobson.
Yes.
Representative Ford.
Representative Soty.
Yes.
Representative Nelson.
representative Luno yes representative Waltz representative Cornell Yes.
Representative Tanner?
Yes.
I forgot Greg Hill.
Okay.
Representative Tanner?
Yes.
I forgot Greg Hill.
Okay.
Representative Hill?
Yes.
Sorry about that.
Representative Walner?
Yes.
Representative Mullen?
Representative Woodcock?
Yes.
Representative Porter?
Representative Hall?
Yes.
representative mullen yes representative woodcock yes representative porter yes representative hall yes and representative lad yes okay so that is 19 yays and zero nays any objection to consent seeing no objection that will be placed on consent the next bill which we have is hb 1648 it's a bill requiring public colleges and universities to implement peer support groups and develop policies for students with mental health conditions this is hb 1648 i recognize represent hobson for a motion Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I recommend HB 1648, inexpedient to legislate for the reason, although...
Not right now.
We've got to get a second on the floor, please.
Rep.
Lakers?
I second.
Thank you.
Rep.
Hobson, you're making the motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
yes I I recommend this bill the ITL because these types of programs are organically happening on the college campus and there is no need to mandate is there any further discussion, Representative Porter?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and I appreciate the ITL motion and understand why, but I do have a concern that the young people who brought this forward had a difficult time finding the services they needed at the community college level.
So I'm more likely to ask for an interim study on this bill so that we can maybe find a common ground that meets all the needs that people are finding.
Thank you.
Any further discussion?
Yes, Representative Cornell.
Yes, I plan on voting ITL, but just because I think it's a great idea, but i think there's too much in it and it encompasses too many different things for too many different places and i'd like to see it broken up a little bit more and it needs more work so i will vote itl but it's just too big further discussion not seeing hands uh reps of uh litchfield The motion is ITL for HB 1648.
It's a bill requiring public colleges and universities to implement peer support groups and develop policies for students with mental health conditions.
Ralph Bohm?
Yes.
Representative Hill?
Representative Litchfield is a yes representative Lakers yes representative Moffat representative Hobson yes representative Ford yes representative Soti yes representative.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Waltz.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Walner.
Yes.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Woodcock.
Representative Porter.
No.
And Representative Hall.
Yes.
And then Representative Ladd.
So we have 17 yes, one no, and one not voted.
It's just 17 of one.
We have 18 present.
Any objections to consent?
Okay, so consent.
Thank you very much.
Next bill we have on the docket is HB 1685.
This is a bill establishing a school facility planning and development program in the Department of Education.
I recognize Representative Boehm for a motion.
Okay, Representative Ford, there's a second.
So we have a motion on the floor.
It's dealing with HP 1685 represent boom do you have any comments or discussion yeah you need to look at what I've got here?
Oh, it's the school planning.
It's the school planning, remember?
Oh.
They couldn't define really the amount of money and all that.
Okay.
Yeah.
And the criteria for the option.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's – we've – this is all part of we've got building aid stuff coming in, and I think this is necessary after we come up with what we want to do with building aid and all that.
So this is premature.
And the criteria.
Okay.
Yeah.
LK speaker the second have any further discussion?
Representative Ford?
No, I know you made a second, but do you have any discussion?
Okay.
Is there any further discussion from the committee?
I'm not seeing any hands.
Thank you very much.
So we have a motion made on 1685.
The motion is to ITL establishing a school facility planning and development program in the Department of Education.
Madam Clerk.
Representative Boehm.
Yes.
Representative Hill.
Representative Litchfield is a yes.
Representative Lakers.
Yes.
Representative Moffitt.
Representative Hobson.
Yes.
Representative Ford.
Representative Soty.
Yes.
Representative Nelson.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Waltz.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Cornell?
Yes.
Representative Tanner?
Representative Walts.
Yes.
Representative Cornell.
Representative Tanner.
Yes.
Representative Walner.
Representative Mellon.
Yes.
Representative Porter.
Representative Hall.
Yes.
And Representative Ladd.
So the vote is 18 to 0.
Yes.
Representative Hall.
And Representative Ladd.
Yes.
So the vote is 18 to 0.
Thank you very much, Madam Clerk.
Is there any objections to consent?
Not seeing any hands.
Thank you.
You're objective?
No, I don't object.
Sorry.
She said 18, and I think we're missing one.
Thank you.
You're objecting?
She said 18, and I think we're missing one.
Is that correct?
Oh, no.
I found my error.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, thank you very much.
So that bill is ITL'd and put on consent.
The next bill we have is HB 1676.
That's relative to making incentive grants for school districts that improve in certain assessment scores.
Recognize Representative Moffitt for a motion.
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I was the prime on this, as you will call for me.
Oh, motion, interim study.
Thank you very much.
And Representative Boehm.
Second.
We'll let the prime speak now.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I was the prime on this.
I obviously believe in the concept and support this.
And the language is from DOE.
Several of us did meet with the Commission and several other folks there were a couple of pieces of this that need a little tweaking I guess so ergo therefore the interim study recommendation any further discussion on this bill just a note that the money for it comes from the rainy day fund.
There's some questions on that.
The concept is a wonderful concept, but when we're talking about various funding mechanisms, we're talking about accountability as well, and some of that will come right into play in accountability.
So no further discussion on that, so let's call the motion on that.
It's relative to making incentive grants for school districts that improve in certain assessment scores.
It's HB 1676 FN.
And the motion is to interim study.
Madam Clerk.
Ralph Boehm?
Yes.
Representative Hill?
Representative Litchfield is a yes.
Representative Lakers?
Yes.
Representative Moffat?
Representative Hobson?
Yes.
Representative Ford?
Representative Soty?
Yes.
Representative Nelson?
Representative Luno?
Yes.
Representative Ford.
Representative Soty.
Yes.
Representative Nelson.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Waltz.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Walner.
Yes.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Porter.
Yes.
And Representative Hall.
Representative Black.
Yes.
And Representative Hall.
Representative Porter?
Yes.
And Representative Hall?
Representative Ladd?
Yes.
So this is a vote of 18 to 0 for interim study.
Thank you very much.
I'd like to apologize to Mary Jane Wollner, Representative Wollner.
I didn't announce that you were taking the position of Art Ellison, and welcome to education.
You're welcome.
Going on to the next bill, which we have on docket this morning.
Doing a good job, folks.
HB 1561, this is relative to school nutrition standards.
I recognize Representative Lakers for a motion I would like to make a motion to ITL.
And Representative Boehm for a second.
Representative Lakers, do you have any discussion?
Just a real quick comment from all of the testimony we got.
This is already being done.
Further discussion from the second?
Oh, wait a minute.
Wrong bill.
That's what I thought.
This is dealing with nutrition requirements.
Yeah, I'm doing two that are similar, and yeah, I pulled the wrong one.
Okay, so this bill clearly has some problems.
It's not really ready for prime time.
We talked about interim study and decided instead we would just ITL and request that the prime kind of go back to the drawing board and do a little more research and come back next year.
Further discussion?
I agree.
One of the, I like to offer just a little discussion.
Remember, this is a bill that had Tier 1 and Tier 2 Thank you.
Further discussion?
I agree.
One of the, I like to offer just a little discussion.
Remember, this is a bill that had Tier 1 and Tier 2 providers, and Tier 1 got a little better deal on the selling of the products or what they got for it.
And Tier 2, my concern was I come from an agricultural community, being Haverhill.
We Hatchland Dairy which is ship's milk all over.
Isn't this the tier two bill?
1561?
This is the whole grains bill.
This is the whole grains and all that.
The whole grains and sugar.
Sodium and all that.
Oh, I see Target.
I've got to get new glasses.
I saw Target 3.
That's the other bill.
I did the same thing as you did, Representative Lakers.
It got me going the wrong way.
Oh, yeah, it's about the whole grains that students sometimes don't really enjoy.
We need more coffee here, I think, Rep.
Ladd.
Compared to the Wonder Bread.
Any further discussion on this bill?
Yes, Representative Walts.
I'm going to vote against ITL because I just think this is an important issue.
I think school nutrition is a really important issue, and I know it's not going anywhere.
It sounds like it's really better for interim study than ITL, and I prefer interim study, so I'm going to vote against it, but I'm not going to be here to study it, so it's not necessarily fair for me to do that to you guys.
Thank you very much for that courtesy.
We do have some bills, but you've got the interim study, and I say several of those biggies are like school finance, budgeting, accountability.
The list goes on, and it's election year as well.
So for time for interim studies.
Thank you very much.
A gal from Rochester.
I came there too.
Just a comment.
Interim study or ITL, it doesn't matter.
You can still make changes and submit a bill next year.
The only thing, interim study is a committee that says they approve it or not.
But you can still come up with another bill next year.
Thank you very much.
Any further discussion?
So we have a motion on the floor for ITL on HB 1561.
The bill is a bill that relative to school nutrition standards.
Representative Litchfield?
Representative Boehm.
Yes.
Representative Hill.
Representative Litchfield is yes.
Representative Lakers.
Yes.
Representative Moffat.
Representative Hobson.
Yes.
Representative Ford.
Representative Soty.
Yes.
Representative Nelson.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative W.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Waltz.
No.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Walner.
Yes.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Porter.
Yes.
Representative Hall.
Yes Hall and representative Ladd yes so the vote for ITL is 17 years in one day representative Waltz do you have any objection to putting on consent thank you very much so we'll put that on consent as well the next bill which we have is HB 1630 yes Thank you.
We're on 1630 right now.
For the awards to philosophy.
so I'd like to recognize Representative Saudi for a recommendation.
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Chair.
The motion is to interim study.
Representative Lakers?
I second.
For the maker of the motion, is there any discussion?
I feel that this needs to be further looked into to see if we could get Socrates off of life support and back into the classroom.
Is there any further discussion?
Representative Tanner.
I think we just need to be really careful about putting too much into the curriculum, too much on the credits for graduation.
It's something as a teacher in school, that was one of the things you looked to this committee and said, oh, no, not again.
So I would agree with the interim study, but I want you to keep that in mind, please.
And I'll make one quick comment, too.
Remember, that is the represent Mullen you sit down in Bedford there did the junior great books program and how to think and and using the thinking type questions when our interpretations the session going beyond just factual and understanding the meaning of what you're looking at and able to get different opinions and it's just a shared inquiry it's a wonderful approach that's integrated into elementary and middle school teaching I feel this an excellent way to get a lot of how you think the rhetoric and the logic that we've been should be accompanying everything we do into curriculum and my feeling is this should transpire and take effect all the way through and be meshed into current curriculum.
And I agree that we have a curriculum that's getting on tilt here, and we're throwing more at the schools.
Days are not being extended, so something gets left out that's hopefully it's not a reading writing and arithmetic so I will be supporting the motion also any further discussion okay madam clerk we have a motion on the interim study requiring eight 1630 requiring high school students to complete a half-year required course and the introduction to philosophy would you please call the roll representative bohm yes representative hill yes representative litchfield is a yes representative lakas yes representative moffitt yes representative hobs Hobson.
Yes.
Representative Ford.
Representative Soty.
Yes.
Representative Nelson.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Walts.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Walner.
Yes.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Porter.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Wallner.
Yes.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Porter.
Yes.
Representative Hall.
And Representative Ladd.
Yes.
So for an interim study on 16-18-0.
So we will put that on consent as well.
Any objections?
Not seeing any objections.
Thank you.
The next bill we're dealing with is 16-27.
This bill establishes an education freedom account program administrator position in the Department of Education and making an appropriation therefore.
I recognize Representative Boehm for a motion.
Make a motion on 1627 to be ought to pass.
And Representative Hobson?
Thank you very much.
Representative Boehm, any discussion?
Yes, I think this is definitely needed with the number of students hopefully going at the EFA, and I think it needs the Department of Education, somebody there to monitor it and run it.
Further discussion?
Yes, Rep.
Sanluno.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
Yeah, I'm going to support the EFA administrator.
I think we did hear, actually, I certainly heard from a couple of DOE directors the necessity of this position being filled to service the EFA program.
But I also hope this administrator will also be able to collect, compile, and provide this committee with detailed information, certainly statistical information, with regards to the EFA program.
Is there further discussion?
Yes, Representative Woodcock.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Back just in time.
My concern is that as we bring this bill forward, we have another hue and cry and need there that's sitting unfilled by DOE.
We have the nursing director's position.
I can't think of a more critical time in our medical history in schools than that position.
And that's not being filled.
And as I understand, if you build on it filled, the money just stands there and we develop a little pool.
I'm not worried about the pool of money that DOE is maintaining for not filling the positions.
What I'm objecting to is the fact that we have another position that they're going to fill, albeit it may be necessary, but surely the nursing position as equally as critical and i'm just upset that once again do we are not going through the only things they pick and choose and uh so therefore i will not be supporting that further than what thank you further discussion not seeing any hands so madam clerk we will uh we have a motion the floor.
Would you please call the roll on HB 1627, establishing an education freedom account program administrator in the Department of Education and making an appropriation.
Therefore.
Representative Boehm.
Yes.
Representative Hill.
Representative Litchfield is yes.
Representative Lakers.
Yes.
Representative Moffat.
Representative Hobson.
Yes.
Representative Ford.
Representative Soty.
Yes.
Representative Nelson.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Walsh.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Walner.
Yes.
Representative.
No.
Yes.
Representative.
Yes?
Yes.
So that is 18 to 1.
Any objections to consent?
Not seen.
Thank you very much.
Yes.
Thank you.
This is the one I was talking about before.
I move ITL on this one.
Second.
Yeah, according to the testimony, we heard this is already being done, so it's unnecessary.
Thank you.
just once again this is another bill that we have that's, you know, an overload on curriculum and totally unneeded.
Thank you very much.
This is a bill dealing with a natural immunity system health and wellness curriculum in the school?
Representative Boehm?
Yes.
Representative Hill?
Representative Litchfield is yes.
Representative Lakers?
Yes.
Representative Moffitt?
Representative Hobson?
Yes.
Representative Ford?
Representative Soty?
Yes.
Representative Nelson?
Representative Luno?
Yes.
Representative Waltz.
Representative Nelson.
Yes.
Representative Luno.
Representative Waltz.
Yes.
Representative Cornell.
Representative Tanner.
Yes.
Representative Walner.
Representative Mullen.
Yes.
Representative Woodcock.
Representative Porter.
Yes.
Representative Hall yes and Representative Ladd Yes Representative Woodcock is that your principal voice?
Thank you What was that final vote please?
19 to 0 Thank you Consent?
Objections?
Thank you We will do that.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I move that we find House Bill 1311 ought to pass.
Second.
Thank you.
Before we continue, Mr.
Chair, I want to spice things up a little bit.
I have an amendment to this bill.
Would you so introduce your amendment?
I would.
It is 2022 0201H.
Is there a second for that?
Okay.
Representative Luno, Madam Clerk can get that down, so it's a different right here.
So the amendment is 0201H.
Motion on the amendment made by Representative Mullen and second by Representative Mullen.
There are copies of the amendment being circulated.
Representative Luna was the second.
And copies are coming around, and we'll discuss that when everybody has a copy of this.
I can see that.
It looks like there's six holes or five holes.
I've been accused of being an overachiever in the past.
Well, I think that comes from breathing the air in Bedford.
No, I would agree with them.
Well, if you taught the junior grade books, you're a thinker, and you're just thinking maybe five are better than three.
Exactly, and now I'm going to ask what people see when they look at the holes, and that will give me loads of information.
Share the query.
I love it.
Okay, everybody has your amendment now.
Can you please explain it?
Yes.
When we met last week and we dealt with House Bill 1311 and House Bill 1234, I made reference to the fact that RSA 189.13a is the RSA that prevents employment in a school system by anything on the Section 5 offenses.
At that time, we were also considering RSA 189.13C, which are the Section 5 offenses that prevent credentialing.
Two different things, two different sections.
The new section, Section C, created by Senate Bill 134 last year.
At that time, it was Representative Cordelli who actually said or asked the question, why are we not considering Section A and Section C concurrently?
Why are we doing it in two steps?
We talked a little bit with Attorney Fenton about the aspect of amending the bill to include Section A and Section C.
So the amendment before you does that.
It adds possession of a controlled substance with the intent to sell and felony assault to the list of Section 5, 189.13C offenses that would prevent credentialing.
Thank you.
That parallels our discussion we had.
Is there any further discussion on this?
Yes, Representative Bohm?
Yes, I'd like to concur because one of the problems we have is what we've heard is a lot of people come to New Hampshire to credential and then don't even work in New Hampshire.
So this will prevent credentialing if they have been convicted of this.
Yeah.
Representative Woodcock.
Thank you.
Representative Maugham, how far does this go back?
Is this retroactive?
Is this current?
How does this work?
That question actually was asked of Attorney Fenton when she was in the hot seat last week.
And it is not retroactive.
So it would go into effect from the effective date should it become law.
Thank you.
And Attorney Fenton is a prosecutor as well.
And yes, we did ask that question.
Further discussion on the amendment?
Then, Madam Clerk, would you please call the roll on the amendment, please?
This is Amendment 0201H to HB 1311.
Representative Boehm?
Yes.
Representative Hill.
Representative Litchfield is yes.
Representative Lakers.
Yes.
Representative Moffitt.
Representative Hobson.
Yes.
Representative Ford.
Representative Soty.
Yes.
Representative Nelson.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Waltz.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Waltz.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Walner.
Yes.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Woodcock.
Yes.
Representative Porter.
Representative Hall.
Yes.
And Representative Ladd.
So this is 19 to 0 on the amendment only.
Yes.
Representative Mullen, do you have a motion?
I do.
I would like to move, Mr.
Chair, that House Bill 1311 be found ought to pass as amended.
Thank you.
Is there a second, Representative Mullen?
Second.
Okay.
We have a motion on the floor right now.
OTPA for HB 1311, prohibiting persons charged with or convicted of certain assault or controlled drug possession violations from employment at public school or being granted teaching credentials.
Is there any further discussion on the OTPA?
Mr.
Chair, could we clarify who made the second, please?
The second was made by Representative Boehm.
Thank you.
If you need more time, Madam Clerk, just tell us.
Barbara Shaw was very vocal in that sometimes.
She'd tell us to hold that up and slow down and let me get things together.
your your job at statutorily is a very important job are you ready now okay we're ready to go ahead on the OTPA motion our vote madam clerk Representative Boehm.
Yes.
Representative Hill.
Representative Litchfield is a yes representative Lakers yes representative Moffitt yes yes representative Ford yes representative Sody yes representative nelson representative luno yes representative waltz yes representative nelson yes representative luno yes representative waltz yes representative cornell yes representative tanner yes representative walner yes representative mullen yes representative woodcock yes representative porter yes representative hall yes and representative lag yes so ought to pass with amendment 19 to 0.
Yes.
Representative Porter.
Representative Hall.
Yes.
And Representative Ladd.
So ought to pass with Amendment 19 to 0.
Any problems with putting on the consent?
Everybody agreeable?
Thank you very much.
The next bill which we have is 1234, HB 1234.
This is a bill relative to criminal background checks for an applicant for a teaching credential.
And I recognize Representative Mullen for a motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
House Bill 1234 adds human trafficking to RSA 18913, Section C.
much in the same way we're a little bit the cart before the horse, horse before the cart.
This would prevent anyone who had been found guilty of human trafficking from being credentialed in New Hampshire.
Yeah, okay.
So I move that it is ought to pass.
Thank you very much.
And Representative Likas, is there a second?
Sure is.
I second.
Thank you.
Representative Mullen, do you have any further discussion?
I do not.
Thank you very much.
Do you have any amendment or anything to this, or it's good to go?
Nope, it's good to go, sir.
Thank you very much.
So any further discussion from committee members?
Not seeing any discussion, Madam Clerk.
We have...
to this it's good to go nope it's good to go sir thank you very much so any further discussion from committee members not seeing any discussion madam clerk we have a motion of ought to pass on hb1234 relative to criminal background checks for an applicant for a teaching credential representative bohm yes representative hill yes representative lichfield is yes representative lakas yes representative moffitt yes representative hobson yes representative ford yes representative sody yes representative nelson yes representative luno yes representative waltz yes representative cornell yes representative tanner yes representative walner yes representative mullen yes representative woodcock yes representative porter yes representative hall yes and representative blad yes so this is ought to pass 19 to 0.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, any objections to consent?
Not seen.
It's on consent.
The next bill which we're dealing with is 1243.
Yeah, I know.
I'm just trying to get my of students for public schools.
I'd like to recognize Representative Boehm for a motion, please.
I make a motion of 1243 of ITL in expedient to legislate.
And Representative Hobson.
That would be me.
Second, please.
Thank you very much.
Representative Boehm, do any discussion?
Yeah, we heard from the Department of Safety of all kinds of problems with this, including liability issues, including liability issues for the drivers that are doing this.
If the school says, okay, you can do this.
We know this is going on anyway.
Drive other students and parents drive other students, but it's not for the school doing it.
So this would allow the school to say, yes, you can drive those others, and that puts a liability issue not only on driver but also on the school.
So ITL.
Is there a further discussion from the committee?
We also heard, of course, from the Department of Safety on this, from the officer that appeared.
Not seeing any further discussion.
Madam Clerk, would you please call the roll.
On HB 1243, relative to alternative transportation of students for public schools.
Representative Boehm.
Yes.
Representative Ford.
Representative Soty.
Yes.
Representative Nelson.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Waltz.
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes This any objection to consent not see any words on consent next bill we have is HB 1058 1058 is relative to the time allowed for public school students to eat lunch.
Mr.
Chairman, I move ITL.
Thank you very much.
Representative Likas.
I second.
Second.
Is there any discussion from Representative Nelson?
Yes, it's really an ideal bill, but here's a big but.
As a former principal and a a teacher I see problems with it working especially in a larger school you either have to extend the days or you're going to have to do something that I don't think is ideal and I think we should leave the scheduling to a local administrator thank you very much is there further discussion I concur it's something that can be decided at the local level, working with your school administration and staff in that school.
Yes, Representative Walz.
So I agree that the schedule proposed in here is not workable, limiting it from 11 to 1, but I really like the idea of making sure kids get 20 minutes to eat.
Because I've actually heard this way back to when my kids were in school about they didn't have enough time to eat lunch.
And I think there's something to be said for assuring that kids have enough time to eat in a healthy fashion.
So I will vote for ITL on this, but I would encourage this committee to in the future pass something or attach something in the form of an amendment that makes sure kids do have 20 minutes to eat, which I don't think is an excessive amount of time.
Thank you very much.
discussion not seeing uh madam clerk would you please call the roll uh on this bill uh the bill is 10 50 uh 10 58 relative to the time allowed for public school students to eat lunch representative bone yes representative Hill yes representative Litchfield is yes representative Lakers yes representative Moffitt yes representative Hobs yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes Yes.
Representative Woodcock?
Yes.
Representative Porter?
Representative Hall?
Yes.
And Representative Ladd?
This is ITL 19-0.
Consent okay?
Got it?
Okay.
Next bill is 1144.
This bill requires public schools to teach labor history.
I recognize represent Ford for a motion.
As what?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You're going the other way, bud.
Okay, thank you.
So the motion is ITL.
Is there a second that comes from Representative Soty?
Thank you.
Discussion?
I believe that this is a curriculum issue and that it's probably already being covered within the courses and the instructors' purview in terms of getting the curriculum approved.
It would include this material.
Further discussion from the second?
Representative Woodcock, then Representative Tanner.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I'd just like to make a comment once again that like Representative Nelson's leaving local scheduling to local school districts, curriculum instruction should be left at the local level and not done in Concord.
Thank you.
It says it's statutory, too.
That's how we have it.
It's a local issue.
Representative Tanner.
Just to add to that, that I think this is important, just like some of the other issues that we've had.
But, again, it's burdensome on the local school district, and it's a local control issue.
Thank you.
And I don't think we want to be getting down in the weeds to in all aspects of our curriculum so with that madam clerk would you please call the roll on HB 1144 the motion is ITL requiring public schools to teach labor history Representative Boehm?
Yes.
Representative Hill?
Representative Litchfield is a yes representative Lakers yes yes yes Yes.
Representative Soty.
Yes.
Representative Nelson.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Waltz.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Walner.
Yes.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Woodcock.
Yes.
Representative Porter.
Representative Hall.
Yes.
Representative Ladd?
This is ITL 19-0.
Any objection to consent?
Not seeing it.
We'll put on consent.
We have two bills left here this afternoon, or this morning.
This morning.
It's great.
It's a good thing because I only had two papers.
Two papers left?
Wonderful.
The whole I gave you.
Okay, the next bill is 1632.
This is relative to civil rights education in public elementary and secondary schools.
I recognize Representative Lakers for a motion.
I would like to move interim study Hobson you have a second I have a second thank you very much represent Lakers you have any discussion yes this this actually talks about instruction which is up to school districts however it is a important topic, and we do need to make sure that it actually is being taught, so that would be the interim study as opposed to ITL.
Further discussion?
Representative Tanner?
Yes, I think we need to be consistent on these.
that, you know, yes, civil rights, labor ed, philosophy, they're all very important.
But curriculum belongs at the local level, and schools are already up to their ears in requirements.
And this just adds one more.
So I will be voting against the interim study, voting hopefully to bring forth a motion for ITL.
Thank you.
Further, yes, Representative Woodcock.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I would support Representative Tanner's position and comments and once again identify that this is not our business instructing, giving instruction to the local school board on what they should do.
And I would yield to Representative Fuhrer, who was here before, the Executive Director of the secondary schools.
He said the teachers' tanks are empty.
The school district administrator's tanks are empty.
We cannot continue to add on.
Thank you.
Representative Porter, did you have your hand up?
I did have my hand up, Mr.
Chair, and I was going to say the same things that Representative Tanner and Representative Woodcock said.
Is there further discussion?
Not seeing any.
Representative Litchfield, would you please call the roll?
The motion is on this bill to interim study HB 1632, a bill to relative to civil rights education in public elementary and secondary schools.
Representative Boehm.
Oh, what do you got green ok yes representative hill yes representative litchfield is yes representative lakas yes representative moffett yes Yes.
Representative Litchfield is yes.
Representative Lakers.
Yes.
Representative Moffitt.
Representative Hobson.
Yes.
Representative Ford.
Representative Soty.
Yes.
Representative Hill.
Excuse me.
Nelson.
Yes.
Representative Luno.
No.
Representative Waltz.
Representative Cornell.
No.
Representative Waltz?
Representative Cornell?
No.
Representative Tanner?
Representative Walner?
No.
Representative Mullin?
Representative Woodcock?
No.
Representative Porter?
Representative Hall?
No.
And Representative Ladd?
Yes.
Okay.
So Bill 1632 for interim study.
The vote is 10 to 9.
Thank you very much.
And we have one bill left.
It's HB 1125.
Yeah, what you got to do is we have sheets there.
They're probably most likely there'll be a minority report on that, I would would assume and so the sheet goes down to and your motion would be to ITL I'm assuming do you have the forms for them?
We'll get that to you.
Okay.
Yeah.
We were talking about that prior bill that we just finished.
We're on 1125 now.
1125 is relative to school emergency plans.
And we have, Representative Hobson, are you prepared for a motion?
I am looking for the amendment 0141.
Okay, we have the amendment right here.
This was, you know, discussed.
We have extra copies right here.
And there's three holes in it we'll let everybody get a hold of this but but we need a motion on the bill itself.
On the bill itself?
I'll pass.
Okay, I'll make a motion to OTP 1125.
Okay, and is there a second from Representative Boehm?
Second.
Okay, now we have discussion, and you would be introducing your amendment on behalf of Representative Cordelli, who is not here today, unable to be here.
Okay.
Mr.
Chair, I'm sorry.
I have not seen the amendment until now.
Okay, so I'll speak to it then.
Okay, thank you.
Yes.
As you all recall, that we had Homeland Security here to speak on this bill.
It's one where we've had in the past Homeland Security has digitized all the site emergency evacuation and plans of all school districts.
And the materials have always passed through DOE to them.
And there was, you know, initially when we did this several years back, there was concern about confidentiality of all materials which were going to homeland security at that time was director perry plumber who was the director of it now we're looking at those information being shipped directly to homeland security but having access and the amendment here changes so there's access to all plans shall be provided to the Department of Education seeing the Department of Education is accountable to make sure these plans are in and they have to have knowledge that Homeland Security has received and they also should have those plans available to themselves too.
Amy Clark being the director over there so this this amendment was written with Homeland Security and Amy Clark at DOE who's in charge of building facilities and emergency matters and security within the schools so the new part is on line 9 and 10 adding in access to all plans shall be provided to the Department of Education.
We want to make sure that the DOE has access to plans which are sent directly to Homeland Security and can help Homeland Security in making sure those plans are delivered, having the accountability from the department.
Yes, Representative Mullen.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Did we not have discussion about changing the September 1 date?
In the amendment, it says that these reports are due to Homeland Security by September 1.
And I think that Amy had suggested that we push it out to, I don't know, maybe October 1 or whatever to give – or the middle of October.
We did have that discussion.
Representative Cordelli is not here.
This is the amendment that – yes, Representative Lakers?
Yeah, we did discuss that, but then decided that schools really should have emergency plans when they start.
Okay.
The emergency plans are sent, and then if they're not updated, the school is responsible for notifying that it remains the same, so they don't have to send all that stuff in again.
So once done, these things ought to be pretty much stable.
Thank you.
Yes, Representative Nelson.
Will these plans be available to the public in some way?
Some bad guy wants to find out.
Could they get them from somewhere?
No, they're not.
And the initial reason why these plans, of course, obviously, we don't want them available to the public.
But they digitize these things so that if you have a sheriff responding or if you have a local police officer or a state trooper responding, they will see these plans.
they will see the digitized map of the building access areas where various systems are located within the building like water and water shut off and all that.
They'll see that in their screens in their car.
So when we had this initially done by Perry Plummer over there, they had a sergeant just tasked with this responsibility loan and they did all that at no cost to the schools at all digitizing these things really important stuff this is very important and and and the one loophole we have right now is we're not really collaborating or had the ability to collaborate between DOE and Homeland Security and that we are trying to do through this bill.
Yes, Representative Tanner.
I think it also goes to emergency services and fire and emergency services.
Exactly.
Yes.
Yeah, the ambulance service even has that.
And they all have this in those vehicles, and that's exactly where we want to be in terms of being prepared for these bad situations.
So is there any further discussion on this?
So did we introduce the amendment?
I'm trying to recall.
No, I asked you if you would mind, because I had not seen it until now.
I was prepared to talk about the bill.
Okay, so we've introduced the bill.
So what we need to do is have this amendment introduced and make a motion.
Yes, I would like to make a motion that we OTP the amendment.
Is that correct?
0141.
Yes.
Is there a second from Representative Boone?
Second.
Okay, we've sort of had this discussion on the amendment already.
Is there Thank you.
0141.
Yes.
Is there a second from Representative Boehm?
Second.
Okay.
We've sort of had this discussion on the amendment already.
Is there any further discussion?
Not seeing any.
Madam Clerk, will you please call the motion on the amendment 0141H, dealing with HB 1125.
Representative Boehm.
Yes.
Representative Hill.
1h dealing with HB 1125 Representative bohm yes Representative Hill Litchfield is yes representative Lakers yes representative Moffat yes Hobson yes Ford yes Representative Soty yes representative.
Representative Nelson.
Yes.
Representative Hall.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Waltz.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Walner.
Yes.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Woodcock.
Yes.
Representative Porter.
Representative Ladd.
Yes.
Representative Porter.
Representative Ladd.
Yes.
Representative Blass.
representative mullen yes representative woodcock yes representative porter yes representative lad yes so the vote on the amendment is 19 to 0.
thank you very much what we have before us right now is representative uh hobson can you make a motion please yes I'd like to recommend HB 1125 ought to pass as amended thank you very much so we have a motion on the table now OTPA on 1125 amending it with 0141 H further discussion madam clerk representative Boehm representative Hill yes Litchfield is yes representative Lakers yes representative moffett yes representative hobson yes representative ford yes representative soti yes representative n yes yes representative Nelson representative Hall representative Luna yes yes yes yes Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Yes.
Representative Walner.
Representative Mullen.
Yes.
Representative Woodcock.
Representative Porter.
Yes.
And Representative Ladd.
So ought to pass with Amendment 19 to 0.
Thank you very much.
Well, we did it.
On consent?
Yeah, on consent.
We made it through everything.
It's 1130, but I i'd like to remind everybody of the 102 bills we've now done 20 and and uh we have nine early bills done though which is good that leaves us um six to go on on the early bill side so um we're making progress.
So, yes.
So was everything except for 1632 on consent?
Yes.
Excellent job.
Yeah, yeah.
We accomplished some things today, which is, I really appreciate everybody trying to keep the discussion down, and I know that education is known for discussion.
However, I think we accomplished something today, and if we can get the type of votes where we come out all on the same page here, that's really a positive.
I agree with you, Representative Luno.
I appreciate everybody's help in doing that today.
I know there was some compromise made on folks here, but I think we came out with the right answer on these bills.
Great job.
We will pick this up again tomorrow.
We have some hearings coming up, and the agenda keeps unfolding like that right through.
I will let you know regarding the issue with the legislation.
It's like Thursday, the mask legislation, what's going on there.
The ruling is if you cannot fit folks into a room or if you're having a scheduling issue in terms of size, you can postpone, but you have to give up 24 hours notice on the postponement and so we're well within that timeframe I will be meeting with folks today try to get a better handle on that where we are working with chief of staff etc so I will let try to let everybody know by by dinner time tonight so but what we will be doing, though, if that is postponed, there will be a hole right there in our schedule.
We will have the opportunity to address some of those other bills, the other 80 bills that we have to deal with, and we're going to try to get on top of that.
This is a huge task, and we'll get through it.
We'll get through it.
And we will be starting at 9 with the first two bills.
Yeah, because they're in the calendar already.
And some people may say, well, I'm going to be down here at 9 o'clock.
And they don't look again at this thing.
And they show up.
So we we'll take advantage if we do postpone those two bills we will exact in that time we will what exec on on thursday if we take those two bills off and have to postpone to trying to be announced that's what the general the process would be We're hearing that their finance room is busy.
We've heard the general of the process would be.
We're hearing that their finance room is busy.
We've heard general court is busy.
And I want to make sure that we have proper security.
I want to make sure we have proper safety for all that are attending.
And that's imperative.
And it's just like a principal would do, right, Representative Woodcock and Representative Nelson?
Yes, usually.
Hopefully always.
I just want to make sure anything that we're going to accept hasn't been something that we've talked about for amendments that we've worked on.
I will.
I'll be in touch with you.
It comes to a point where we're going to have to start exacting some of these very difficult controversial bills.
It's got to come up.
There's no really easy bills.
Yeah, there is in terms of our acting.
Every bill somebody's put some time into.
And so we want to be respectful in that regard.
So I really appreciate what's happened today.
We're done for right now.
People have 1 o'clock.
I got a 1.30.
I got a percent in another meeting.
So thank you for coming.
Ripson Hobson.
Hi, thank you.
I just wanted to look ahead to the calendar next week.
It looks as if there will be subcommittee meetings on Monday and potentially no education hearing on Tuesday.
Is that what I see correctly?
I will look.
I believe that is correct.
We have hearings strung out throughout Wednesday the 2nd.
On the 3rd, we have hearings as well.
And on the 4th, we also have hearings.
So that's why you got the Tuesday off, because we're working four days a week, in some cases for those that are on these subcommittees, it could be five days a week, and it has been.
We had two subcommittee work groups yesterday, one dealing with a four-year degree offered by the community college system, and the other was dealing with the foundational budget bill.
Those will continue for the next two Mondays.
We'll continue.
Also, I have added in on the Tuesday, the February 8th, you'll see in the calendar that we have one bill at 145, and then we stop.
I've set something up for 2.30 when inviting over the Commissioner of Agriculture and Marketing, et cetera, over here.
Remember, we had a couple farm bills, which we wanted more information from the department.
So we will be doing that it will be a work session committee of the whole committee of the whole so I'm not saying you're on it you're not on it everybody's welcome in a committee the whole and we will be looking at that was one of the bills that I addressed today in a proper I guess when I was talking to your one tier two and there's the other bill agriculture in the classrooms that committee there may be some need for us to realign the structure of that committee the committee is made up of non legislators remember as you recall other organizations and there's issues regarding profit nonprofit and all that in on terms of these various groups so we want to get to the bottom line that commissioner jasper does have some uh thoughts on that so he'll share it with us so that's that will be on tuesday february 8th at 2 30.
so anything else for the good yes i want to i want to thank Rep Walner and Rep Hill for coming today did did a great job of course we have represent Waltz here too and of course she always does a good job because she's Rochester okay there anything else?
If you haven't signed that sign-in sheet here, did everybody have a chance to do this?
Okay, thank you very much.
Have a good lunch.
I got two blurbs, 1685 and 1243.
This is my sheet right here.
So you did right here.
What was this one?
Alternative transportation.
Thank you.